[Musique]
il a pris la barre qu'elle était là sur
le lac avec une arme donc j'avais même
pas connaissance
et
[Musique]
tu ne craint plus rien il a dit que
j'avais raison dans sa lettre
mais par rapport à quoi je sais pas je
croyais qu'on avait aucun secret tout le
monde a des secrets
[Musique]
garacad femme qui me ressemblent toutes
un peu mais pas complètement non plus
arrête maintenant lorsque tu trouveras
ya rien qui peut aider aujourd'hui je
crois que vous avez connu mon mari il
faut que vous sachiez un truc
qu'est-ce qu'il construisait
c'était notre maison mais inversés
[Musique]
et j'avais peur de ne plus pouvoir
refouler sont refoulés quoi
tu vas pas bien
[Musique]
c
bientôt la poule
[Musique]